Traductor: Almudena Torrecilla
Revisor: Sofía de la Canal
En 1970, la marihuana se definió
como droga de clasificación 1 en EE. UU.,
la clasificación más restrictiva,
pasando a ser totalmente ilegal y
sin ningún uso medicinal reconocido.
Este punto de vista se mantuvo
durante décadas,
impidiendo la investigación sobre los
mecanismos de la droga y sus efectos.
Hoy en día, los beneficios terapéuticos de
la marihuana son ampliamente reconocidos
y algunos países han legalizado su uso
médico o están en proceso de hacerlo.
Pero el creciente reconocimiento de su
valor medicinal no responde a la pregunta:
¿es el uso lúdico de la marihuana
perjudicial para el cerebro?
La marihuana actúa en el sistema
cannabinoide
que tiene receptores distribuidos
por el cerebro y por el cuerpo.
El cuerpo posee unas moléculas
llamadas endocannabinoides,
que actúan sobre estos receptores.
No entendemos el sistema cannabinoide
en su totalidad,
pero posee una característica
que nos da la clave de su funcionalidad.
La mayoría de los neurotransmisores
viajan de neurona en neurona
propagando un mensaje
a través de la sinapsis.
Pero los endocannabinoides viajan en
dirección opuesta.
Cuando un mensaje pasa de una neurona
a la siguiente,
la neurona receptora
libera endocannabinoides.
Estos hacen el recorrido contrario
hasta la neurona emisora
proporcionándole información
de la neurona receptora.
Esto hace pensar a los científicos que
el sistema endocannabinoide
sirve principalmente para modular
otro tipo de señales,
amplificándolas y disminuyéndolas,
según los casos.
La retroalimentación de los
endocannabinoides
ralentiza el ritmo de las
señales neuronales
Esto no implica que necesariamente
ralentice el movimiento o la percepción.
Por ejemplo, ralentizar una señal
que inhibe la capacidad olfativa
podría, de hecho, intensificar los olores.
La marihuana contiene dos
componentes activos principales,
tetrahidrocannabinol o THC,
y cannabidiol o CBD.
Al THC se le atribuyen principalmente
los efectos psicoactivos de la marihuana
sobre el comportamiento,
la cognición y la percepción,
mientras que el CBD es responsable de
los efectos no psicoactivos.
Al igual que los endocannabinoides,
el THC ralentiza la transmisión de señales
al unirse a los receptores cannabinoides.
Pero se une simultáneamente a todos los
receptores de este extenso sistema,
mientras que los endocannabinoides
se liberan en un lugar específico.
como respuesta a un estímulo concreto.
Este radio de acción tan amplio junto
con el hecho de que el sistema
cannabinoide afecta indirectamente
a muchos otros sistemas
significa que la química cerebral,
la genética y las experiencias de cada
persona determinan en gran medida
los efectos de la droga.
Esto se da en mayor medida
en la marihuana,
ya que otras drogas afectan un único
circuito o algunos específicos.
Así que los efectos dañinos, si los hay,
son muy distintos en cada persona.
Y aunque no sabemos de forma precisa
cómo la marihuana
produce sus efectos nocivos,
hay claros factores de riesgo que
aumentan la probabilidad de
que la gente los sufra.
El factor de riesgo más claro es la edad.
En menores de 25 años, los receptores de
cannabinoides presentan mayor
concentración en la materia blanca,
que en mayores de 25 años.
La materia blanca actúa sobre
los procesos de comunicación,
aprendizaje, memoria y emociones.
El uso frecuente de la marihuana puede
alterar el desarrollo de los surcos
de la materia blanca, y dañar la capacidad
cerebral de crear nuevas conexiones.
Esto puede dañar las capacidades de
aprendizaje a largo plazo
y de resolución de problemas.
Por ahora, se desconoce cuán
severo puede llegar a ser el daño,
o si es reversible.
E incluso entre los jóvenes, el riesgo
es mayor cuanto menor es la edad.
Por ejemplo, es mayor en un joven de 15
años que en uno de 22.
La marihuana también puede causar
alucinaciones y delirios paranoicos.
Conocida como psicosis cannábica,
los efectos disminuyen normalmente
cuando se deja de consumir marihuana.
Pero en casos aislados,
la psicosis no disminuye,
sino que desenmascara un desorden
psicótico permanente.
Los antecedentes familiares de
desorden psicótico, como la esquizofrenia,
son el factor de riesgo más claro,
aunque no el único.
La psicosis cannábica también se da más
entre adultos jóvenes, aunque cabe señalar
que, de todas formas, estos desórdenes
suelen revelarse en este rango de edad.
Lo que no está claro es si el desorden
psicótico habría aparecido
sin el consumo de marihuana;
o bien la marihuana lo dispara antes de
tiempo y es un catalizador para un punto
de inflexión que no se habría
desencadenado sin ella,
o bien si la reacción por el uso de
marihuana indica simplemente
un desorden subyacente.
Con toda probabilidad, el efecto de la
marihuana difiere de unos a otros.
Igual que ocurre con otras drogas,
a cualquier edad, el cerebro y el cuerpo
se vuelven menos sensibles a la marihuana,
con el consumo continuado,
lo cual implica que hay que ingerir mayor
cantidad para lograr los mismos efectos.
Afortunadamente, y no como
sucede con otras drogas,
no hay riesgo de morir
de sobredosis de marihuana,
e incluso un consumo exagerado
no provoca síntomas de abstinencia
debilitantes o potencialmente mortales
si se deja de consumir.
La marihuana provoca, sin embargo,
otros síntomas de abstinencia más sutiles,
como trastornos del sueño,
irritabilidad y carácter depresivo
que desaparecen a las pocas semanas
de dejar de consumir la droga.
Así que ¿es la marihuana
dañina para el cerebro?
Depende de quién seas.
Pero, si bien hay factores de riesgo
que son fáciles de identificar,
otros no se conocen completamente,
lo que implica que siempre está
la posibilidad de
sufrir efectos negativos,
incluso aunque no tengas ninguno
de los factores de riesgo conocidos.